bah la corruption est un est plus qu'un
risque puisqu'on sait que au Pays-Bas et
en Belgique c'est un modus opérandi
extrêmement efficace et que les gens qui
refusent de se faire corrompre sont
menacés leur familles le sont et cetera
et cetera donc on connaît cette réalité
hein d'ailleurs la presse s'en fait écho
tout ça est en est parfaitement connu
donc ce que ce que nous voulons faire
c'est assez simple hein c'est de mettre
nos agents à l'abri de ce genre de
menace pour être à ce genre de menace il
faut que le dispositif soit en
permanence sous surveillance par exemple
j'ai une caméra ici je peux toujours
dire à la personne qui souhaite me
corrompre écoutez j'aimerais bien
mais pas possible donc c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on fasse c'est qu'on déplo un
dispositif qui fasse que l'agent qui
soit docker qui soit fonctionnaire
militaire sera toujours en mesure s'il
le souhaite de trouver la capacité de
résister à ça donc il faut vraiment
mailler complètement le dispositif pour
qu'il a une traçabilité de toutes
personnes sur les ports et pour
permettre à nos à nos agents de de de
résister enfin après il y a il y a
toujours des êtres faibles et qui se
laisseront corrompre mais on sait
comment finit ce type de corruption elle
finit assez mal et encore une fois
l'hypothèse des que les
narcotrafiquants arrivent à par ce biais
à ébranler nos nos Fondements r
publicuicain me paraît une hypothèse
assez sérieuse hein euh